Oh most distinguished ladies and
respectable gentlemen it is my pleasure
to welcome you to multiple blares uh
Christopher what is your host and
joining me today in a Victorian era
beat-'em-up blow em up for player I'm
not gonna talk like that no worthy
Christopher thank you for having me on
your life series my pleasure Kevin's of
an old why I can't do the points and so
on thank you Oh Eric you didn't even
give it a try lad I don't have it
doesn't have it just like you don't have
gentlemen skills and I'm about to blow
you up with some pigeons way too early
mom we are gonna be playing gentlemen
it's for player murder each other type
game as we like so much here it's built
by three dudes in edinboro yeah I'm
gonna do the thing like the character
over my system here we go let's all do
that ya ready gotta get in there to go
in there we go here we are basically
there's there's two buttons what you
move and then you can under my own
immerse gravity and that's how you jump
Oh homing pigeon yo Gina's week and then
there's like an attack button it's so
slow oh I'm all bombs know what
attacking me moms go to help
I don't know who's also i got a bum nice
okay these men listen what do I have so
you can tell what weapon you have Oh
shucks jitsu not likely Oh weapon you
have by looking at the top of the screen
blue so what would we what we have a
couple different weapons we've got
knives ah Americans oh my goodness get
that get that Oh give me something your
weapons change when you grab a box who
I'm is enough so I'm working working the
shock now so as the adore it looks like
I don't know what I'm doing yeah it's
like it oh I canceled pigeon pigeon
cancel next level pigeon canceling what
what happened no weapons oops no way see
do you have like oh I just killed myself
with bomb i want the night oh yes loma
your quizzes uh but like when you get a
kill that little like we love skulls
pops up and mom around you and fills in
one or it's a wheel Oh skull oh ok schwa
it's gonna be real I'm an engine oh I
keep myself in my own ball oh the pigeon
goes through walls [ __ ] doesn't care
not care she's not care massager man i
really want to be able to walk out I did
with quad neighbors oh oh yeah our way
from me get pigeon Oh angle on the quad
neck all coming for the final kill Joe
get a little touch-up oh I call I killed
a pigeon with my bomb yeah I don't know
you could do that most sinister burner
ahaha
see this water what's not dynamite it's
not so there we go oh where is Sean what
have I got what do I get on our dynamite
have pigeons are the worst oh I killed
someone like that though okay okay the
Lightning's know why am i okay night hey
nice oh oh oh can you get away okay this
dynamite away free 3g business oh ok the
shock attack is pretty okay yeah the
[ __ ] he just run it um not gonna lie I
don't like the homing pigeon at all like
what does it we just do a thing anak it
always you can do a homing pigeon with
other weapon yes it just flies around
and get hit my stuff no I know what a
woman's give me a weapon ah no stop
taking your leg criss-cross knives all
step directly on all good night oh the
knife is nasty I totally one of those is
amazed this sick oh no I'm got a crazy
dynamite trail oh man oh these knives
these Christmas my eyes no no give me
the electricity I just get away pitch
went oh my god will pick out a pigeon
kill I'm so excited no I don't want ya
hold the fam
Oh to time it oh oh that's not fair Oh
Michael yeah I'm so flush it out ya know
Oh goose but we're doing this again
we're gonna see the dragon run back oh
there's straight night oh yeah I got
invulnerability I think it's just know
there's the night she died again looks
like and now a quieted sensible settles
over the couch like boom come on Adam
got a double kill oh I'm terrible with
nice okay we gotta do anything I like
not yet you kill telling us I feel like
knives with the equalizer I don't like I
know knives I don't like Giles at least
it's not the quad knife yeah Claud not
me yeah we did would be too weird ah how
does it whose green oh you're right i
was an event like this in a bit is it
wasn't of it is that the first time
we've actually seen that are yes yay
everybody come to madonna my party no
weapons and no weapons except for vol
damage please sit directly on that ah i
had a weapon for a mere Matilda no this
is it this is it Oh first rail on the
board he shut out on the board
oh don't let me get into my Tesla's oh
my goodness no what no what oh my sweet
sweet oh I just had it long I was like
how come I can't pick anything up come
here no drinking I just killed myself
god no Oh mr. box I need oh oh oh how
did you run all the time I don't want
the night okay that was terrible cuz I
kept killing my you're about to die
right there I know what the heck the
people's win right there oh oh oh man
come on I was right over your head run
okay no one in the play knives it was
his forte let it go way to go hey sound
like one strength and his game wait a
minute I need inspiration you go take a
hit off of that oh yeah guys everywhere
no stop that whoever dude oh my goodness
i thought i had that
ah ah ah I've done cha cha oh no kills
or something oh wow there's so many
pigeons right now your page there's so
many pictures I'm so scared I'm so
scared look at Bridget not doing
anything you're like thought to kevin
was like oh no I'm good yeah I'm going
on that's how pigeons do a piece oh I
got amazing I got good Higgins oh he
might mind everything that I do Oh Erica
salon was a painting one with the pizza
Higgins don't know Tesla no way Oh what
you want with your pin yesh hitting the
post post mortem pigeon whoa that was
stressful duh I think that's it oh
you're the you tell them one more oh oh
all right one more kiss wants to do
today that was another short Chan yeah
that was it they were good why is there
so much pigeon it's just like he's got
Tesla no get paid oh come on it isn't
crossed knife I'm just gonna bury my
face in there I'm just gonna keep piling
up Higgins oh I do this either come on
come on can we give it oh go look at the
kitchen you see that you were right into
it spit it did nothing Maxwell is
dominating this match I'm sucking wow
this is terrible no I'm taking away all
your business I'm taking away your
weapon again oh oh look at that eyes
makes the way I think he got out a
post-mortem kill I'd like to I'd like to
not talk about my performance in that
last man we'll talk about the whole game
dead Kevin a gentleman on the whole like
what do you think from a Victorian
gaming perspective I can't do the voice
but yes it's good this is fun fun i wish
we could do this all day now because
that was fun ah but no we have to do
other live shows today we've got the
lobby coming up today at 2pm special GDC
episode we're going to be giving away
tons of beta codes for smite we're going
to be giving away we're going to start a
brand playstation 4 infamous second side
for a year of playstation plus giveaway
keep an eye on gamespot com / ps4 give
away also
super time force is gonna be here I
Peter Molyneux is gonna be here is he
gonna play super time force no I was
gonna play goddess okay gave a heat made
ah so we're gonna do that at two p.m.
please come back and join us then
Maxwell I feeling gentlemanly are you
I'm feeling real feeling real pretty
right now cuz Kevin okay we're going
down take a fur coat us Thank always on
to this dubious pleasure to have you
here because you're now on in too good
at video games thanks for watching y'all
much appreciated and I will see you
today 2 p.m. at wear's
I